[Music]
horri bachelor crystals could be facing
manslaughter charges tonight
welcome everyone Nancy O'Dell is off Ali
Fedotowsky mano is here in a former
Bachelorette and part of that world you
know Chris well I do were actually
friend and I mean everybody in the
bachelor world our friends our paths are
always crossing all the time we go to
weddings together and reunions and I
truly never expected anything like this
to happen yeah indeed Chris was out on
bail today after a car crash that left
one man dead
the former bachelor star was in an Iowa
courtroom this morning accused of
leaving the scene of this deadly
accident last night
Chris soules was taken into custody at
1:16 a.m. police say Souls was driving
southbound on this rural County Road
when his pickup hit the back of a
tractor it drove the tractor into the
east ditch Souls vehicle drove into the
West ditch driver of the tractor
unconscious in the ditch one of the
subjects that was involved just took off
northbound and arrestor a Mack truck
we the name on the subject is going to
be crystal that could be the subject
that took off Souls was arrested at home
he was not charged with driving under
the influence
but his criminal complaint says that he
quote possessed alcoholic beverages /
containers in a statement today Souls
acknowledged he was involved in last
night's incident and was devastated to
learn that the other person in the
accident passed away we checked online
court records in Iowa and learned that
crystals has had at least 14 run-ins
with the law in Iowa
most of these were vehicle related
offenses speeding failed breaks running
stop signs and leaving a theme and he
also pled guilty in 2006 to operating a
vehicle while intoxicated
so did ABC know about souls priors
before signing him up for the bachelor
when we asked the network they declined
to comment souls is a fourth-generation
Iowa farmer who appeared on season 19 of
The Bachelor before that he finished
third on The Bachelorette just last
month the reality star joked with us
about how drinking helped him to relieve
the pressures of reality TV I just used
whiskey for my therapy the last two
weeks I couldn't sleep so I wake up at
about 3 a.m. and I'd go work out and
then I'd then I'd have a little whiskey
for breakfast after court today souls
posted $10,000 bail and was released
from this I would jail we've learned
sold had to turn in his passport which
will likely force him to miss a bachelor
related event he was scheduled to attend
out of the country were also told he
will have to be monitored with an ankle
bracelet at the end of the day a man
lost his life and this is just such a
heartbreaking situation
you